all right
well it's 10 20 by my watch so
let's get started thanks for hanging out
uh welcome to i guess session one of ndc
sydney in room one thank you for
joining me um for joining from wherever
you are which
is easier uh if you want to turn on your
cameras that's great i can see you over
there and
you can smile or not and if you don't
that's cool too uh if you have any
questions
feel fr ask in the slack channel i've
got that open as well
and that's a bit easier to track than
the webex
chat but let's get started let's talk
about source generators
let's talk about writing code to write
some code
so source generation in general is
a concept that is very um
i say it might not be familiar to every
developer but every developer pretty
much uses it even if they don't know
and i think it's an idea that will
appeal to every developer
because it's all about automation it's
all about
taking something you don't want to do in
this case writing some code
and making a computer do it which is
maybe kind of what
we're all sort of in this job for anyway
and as i sort of said we all probably
use source generation
in general terms every day if you've got
a dot-net project that sdk-style.net
project
that doesn't have an assembly info for
example that is general
at build time by a source generator it's
not a c
sharp 9 source generator that i'm going
to be talking about mainly but it's
still
source generation if you've got a resex
file or a razor file or even an aspx web
forms
file all of those things have source
generation
as part of how they work it's all about
automating some stuff
in the case of resexes and razor files
and things it's you know to
save you from having to write this class
that represents what you want your
output to be
it's generated so that's the general
concept
and there's a few different ways that
that works currently so let's
quickly do a bit of background on what
these things look like so
at a very high level this is very high
level
as you can see this is what happens when
you build your project
you have your c-sharp files which are
hand-written by you presumably
they go into the compiler and that
produces a dll
cool makes sense so the two ways that
source generation can work
now and by now being before c-sharp nine
uh so there's two ways the first way is
before the compilation and so you might
see things like ms build tasks being
used for this
uh there's tools like codesmith which is
one i used to use
15 years ago um and then there's all
sorts of other options as well there's
there's single file generators built
into visual studio
lots of different options here but
basically what they do is they
will look at the files on your disk and
generate some code based off them so
this is where the resex or the asp
razor file generation comes in now look
at those files and just generate some
code c
sharp code and that all goes to the
compiler together
the compiler essentially doesn't know
which code you wrote versus which code
was written by
someone else which is doesn't matter but
that's essentially to the compiler this
isn't all just
code one big lump code and it all comes
into your deal alien
the other way you can do source
generation now is after the compilation
this is where there's tools like post
sharp you might have heard of or foddy
and these work at a very different level
these work at the il level
so your c-sharp code is converted to il
that's what puts in the dll
these tools work by changing the il
directly they're called il weavers
usually
and the way these work
is very different and foddy and post
sharp sort of work as
tools that allow you to uh to make that
job easier right so you don't have to
actually
use il you can write c sharp code that
uses their libraries but
essentially the way these work is
i would say this is the most powerful
option right these can change
the il of any dll you produce or even
any dll we reference
if we forget for a second about things
like code signing and strong naming and
certificates and whatever
we assume there's no security in the
world because it's easier
these tools could change any dll in your
whole project
so we kind of have these two extremes at
the moment where we have this extreme
power
on the right hand side for post
compilation generation
and then we have generally speaking the
easier to use options
before the compiler gets to it so
what's new and what i'm going to be
focusing on from now on
is g sharp 9 brings its own
source generation uh feature into it
and this is the first sort of inbuilt
what's the first generation option built
into the compiler there's various
options built into visual studio and
other microsoft products things like t4
templates etc
but this one's built into the compiler
so before we talk about that though
let's just talk quickly about what the
compiler does so
digging into this black box of a
compiler or a pink box of a compiler
what happens when your c sharp files are
compiled so the compiler is made up of
phases there's about five of them
but there's three that are sort of
relevant here the first thing that
happens to your c sharp files is they go
through the paths phase
and this is where the text of your files
the c sharp code itself
gets parsed and converted into a syntax
tree
now this is a concrete syntax tree for
the currency sharp compiler but
don't worry about what whether that's
what that means it's just a syntax tree
it is a tree representation of all of
the bits of your code
that syntax tree is then sent into the
compile phase
and from that it becomes we get a
compilation
the compilation is adding in all of the
rich
information about the type system so for
example if you had a variable that was
declared as a string
with a lowercase s well the person knows
that that's the string
keyword in c sharp so that's going to be
a keyword node
but if you use a capital s the parser
doesn't know what that means
it's just a type called string it has no
idea where it comes from
the compilation is what adds in that
type information say ah this is a
system.string
from mscorellib.dll or whatever it is
and so then that compilation goes to the
emit phase
and it becomes il and that's what gets
sent to our dll
so that's our high level view of the
compiler let's add source generators
into the mix
so a source generator is something you
tell the compiler about
you provide essentially you say hello
please use this source generator for me
what happens now is your code goes into
the parse phase
produces a syntax tree goes into compile
syntax true becomes a compilation
and what happens now is different now
what happens is
the compilation and those syntax trees
get sent across
to the source generator so in the middle
of the compiler
we are now able to provide this library
that says hey
while you're compiling my other code
over here
also run this code that i'm giving you
or this library
the source generator then generates
source obviously
which is a string it's just a string of
c sharp code so of course the string
has to go through the path phase becomes
the syntax tree
that syntax tree becomes a compilation
we combine
that compilation with the one from our
project and we mush them together
and then that final result of all of
this gets sent through the emit phase
becomes il and gets sent out to your
project so the source
generator allows you to hook into the
compiler pipeline
and allows you to add in more code that
will be sort of become
part of the dll the source generator
itself
doesn't move it doesn't ever become part
of the dll you don't have to distribute
it
it's only at compile time
so some potentially frequently asked
questions
things that seem to come up a lot just
to preempt maybe
some questions so does the source
you generate exist on disk this is sort
of the first
seems to be the first reaction everyone
has to these things is okay how do i see
these files
and it's a bit weird because by default
you can't
they don't exist this is all happening
in memory in the compiler
you're writing strings and they're
getting converted to memory streams and
that's it
there is an option to emit them and it's
good for debugging
but it's not something that you know you
you use it's it's it's an anti-pattern
if you want to try and read those
generated files and decide if you should
run etc whatever whatever
you're supposed to let the compiler work
out that you should run
can you have multiple source generators
absolutely but
they each have to be independent you
cannot have source generators that
rely on other source generators so you
can't build up this layered approach
and this is a challenge for some
sort of raising out their designs
and it'll be interesting to see this is
a space that i think might
change there's some proposals around at
the moment for having uh
two levels of source generators so you
could opt into being
the first level and then the second
level could depend on the first one
um but we'll see but yeah this this does
mean that if you want to
if you want to have you know a half a
dozen different source generators for
your project because you've got all
these crazy ideas that's great
but you can't you know build upon them
at the moment
the next question that everyone asks
when they start to write a source
generator especially
is how come i have to make strings of c
sharp code this seems crazy
and it kind of is crazy but it also kind
of makes sense
uh so there are
higher level concepts for code right
there's syntax treats we just talked
about them that's what you get to
use when you're writing a source trigger
but
allowing you to produce a syntax tree
directly
is a a very big well it's not a problem
but it's a big challenge the c-sharp
compiler it turns out is really good at
compiling c-sharp code
from a blob of c-sharp but compiling
arbitrary syntax trees
is just not it's not as well tested
and it's pretty easy to break the
compiler or just have the compiler
produce
code that is not what you expect because
and i'll show you this in a minute but
the syntax trees in c sharp the reason
they're called concrete syntax
trees is because they're super detailed
they contain
every single character of your c sharp
file including all the white space and
all the comments and everything
and in fact they go two ways if you like
from a syntax tree you can produce
the code that produced it and it is
identical
and so because of that the syntax trees
needed to
be valid c sharp are really detailed and
they're actually a little bit of a pain
to produce
and then can they change vote so this is
the
the really big uh
kind of a gotcha about c sharps or
stereos or at least a
a major difference between the existing
options
and this new option they cannot change
existing code you cannot modify anything
you can only add new code so if you
remember that little diagram
your c files produce a syntax tree they
produce a compilation
and then the source generator produces
more code that gets added to that
compilation there's no changing now
this is another one of those things
where
i think there's a bunch of ideas people
might have for source generators and
you get to this point where oh i can't
change code and all your ideas
some of your ideas just fall on the
floor um so this is a bit of a challenge
but
this is also kind of why we have them
these things have been talked about and
discussed in in the compiler planning
for years
and it is just a huge hurdle to get over
if they have to change code so they can
only act but there's a few ways you can
sort of work with that so we'll cover
that
and then the ide experience um the
visual studio in the latest preview so
uh 16.8 to preview three and above
it's a pretty good experience if you're
using source generators
it's not as good for writing source
generators
there will be more work coming in that
area but for now
there's a few rough edges and that's
basically just because visual studio
being.net framework once it loads your
source generator
it can't unload it and therefore it
can't load
the next version with your you know
changes so
there's a few little things there but i
can show you that too
all right so what can you do with them
so this is definitely
just my opinion but i sort of see source
journalism falling into
three main buckets so the first one
is performance essentially
in a lot of cases where you've got code
that uses reflection
you can change them to be source
generators and you can inspect that code
at compile time instead of runtime and
you get a huge performance boost
a couple of examples there in case
anyone wants to refer back for any
questions later that's fine
um i'll i'll talk through the winforms
enum validator that i wrote
um as the second half of this talk is
just going to be
talking through it too um but yeah
getting rid of reflection is a huge
boost to performance and
if it's possible uh moving all of that
work onto the compiler
or at compile time um is a huge win
the other one is the automatic to
automate processing of external files so
this
could be things like serializers xml
serializer json serialize or
deserializers
um there's a source generator in
rosalind
that generates the so from the
c sharp grammar file the the file that
describes the language
we generate a bunch of code for
accessing
that right basically all those syntax
tree node classes are all generated
um that's a good example um anything you
provide with additional files in your
project file
can be seen by source generators so you
can automate the processing of those
things
and again sometimes that's just a matter
of moving work from runtime to compile
time but sometimes it's
a bit more than that too and then
finally there's just the
sort of the obvious one of i don't want
to type this code all the time so make
someone else do it for me
things where i've used source generation
in the past
for this is things like custom orms or
this is sort of what if you use the
entity framework or linkedis sql
designers in visual studio where you
draw the tables out and link them up etc
all of that generation that generates
classes and properties and things
whatever
that's pretty boring stuff uh so
generating that
is potentially a good win things like uh
you know mapping and whatever else
so there's a few other little things
that we can do with source genres i'm
gonna
run through quickly um source generators
can report
diagnostics which is a fancy way of
saying build errors
so as part of the running of the source
generator you can
essentially stop the build of the
project that's consuming it
so this is a good way to add in
validation around what you're generating
it's tempting to also add in validation
of the project you're compiling
but try not to do that because that's
what roles and analyzers are for
but they do perform the same job so your
generator can
report a diagnostic it'll appear in the
build log it'll appear in visual studio
you know everything that uses compiler
diagnostics
just sees this as another compiler it
doesn't know that it came from your code
instead of the compiler
as i briefly mentioned they can access
additional files so any
file in your project that you put in the
additional files group
in your source journal you can just
iterate through them and
go nuts there's a a link at the bottom
there
which i'm not going to talk through but
it's an interesting idea
not for production use probably but it's
essentially a c-sharp project you you
using the source editor to create a
c-sharp project that has no c-sharp in
it
but just has additional files then those
additional files are processed by a
source area
and so my friend scott wrote uh a source
generally that
transpiled a language essentially a
non-dominant language
write the parser as a source generator
and then
output c sharp um anyway
a bit crazy but it works usage notes yes
that's right that's what's next um
so some other things around source
generators that are
uh good to mention um so i said they
can't change code and that's
really important so one of the
mechanisms you can use in c sharp
to allow your source generator to sort
of access
the you know in into the middle of where
your real code is
because it can't change it is to use
partial methods
and so because of this and because of
source changes partial methods got a bit
of a boost
in c sharp nine so before c sharp nine
this is what partial methods look like
you would have
partial void method you would call that
method from
some other bit of code and then
somewhere
be it handwritten or not you would
define the implementation of that method
and the way this worked before c sharp 9
was if you didn't provide that
implementation ever then that method
call just went away
it was it was though it never existed so
if you if you
assume that i you know don't have this
bottom half of this slide
this line of code here would just not be
compiled into the dll
and so because that can happen and
because that that line can be removed by
the compiler
there was a lot of restrictions on
partial methods so you couldn't return
anything from them
you could leave out parameters right
because if you're removing that line of
code well what would the return type be
what would the value be all those sort
of things um
and you couldn't have access modifiers
so they couldn't be public because
it might not exist they actually
couldn't be private either they couldn't
be anything you literally weren't
allowed to type in an access modifier
but so to make these more useful for
source generators in c sharp nine
basically all of those rules have been
flipped on the head
so they can have return types now they
can have our parameters
they can have access modifiers but
if you have any one of those things then
you have to provide an implementation so
basically
you can now make them real methods but
if you want them to be real they have to
exist essentially they're not optional
and so this means that you can define
your method signature for a method that
will exist in future
you can call it although i should have
updated this slide because
clearly that's not the right number of
parameters anymore uh but you can call
it
and know it will be there and then your
source generator can fill in the body
essentially
so this is a way to sort of not really
edit code
but put a spot to say hey source
generator
here's where i want you to fill in the
gaps so you provide these little holes
in your code
knowing that something will come and
fill them in later
all right so quickly how do we actually
reference them
uh and how do we create them they're
pretty simple so up the top
uh left those two little snippets of
project file
is the two ways that you can reference
them essentially they reference the
exact same way that you reference an
analyzer if you're
doing any custom roster analyzer work at
the moment
so one is just with a direct dll
reference and this normally you know
would be hidden away by a nuget package
obviously
you can reference them as a project so
if you've got a source generator in your
solution along with your actual project
you can just reference it that way
there's a little bit of extra little
guff here so reference output assembly
was false which basically says
this isn't a dependency that you want to
reference it's not a library of code i'm
going to be using
it's just something i want to build
first and then the output item type is
saying well instead of being a normal
reference this is an analyzer reference
and then to actually create a source
generator is really straightforward
um which is the bottom two pictures if
you like so
the the biggest thing to remember they
have to be done at standard 2.0 they
cannot be any other target framework
and that's just because the compiler is
cross-platform so
net standard 2 will work anywhere it's
safe
and then you reference the those two
packages the code analysis.analyzers and
the c-sharp workspaces
[Music]
i actually think only one of them is
needed to actually create a source
generator but
you kind of can't do much with it if you
don't have the other one but so you
reference those packages
and to actually create a source chain on
it it's
pretty simple you create a class you put
the generator attribute on it
you implement i source generator and
then there are two methods there's an
initialize method and an execute method
and that's it and if you look at that
picture this is like
the world's simplest source generator
you create some
code in a string as mentioned so this is
a class called foo
and then i don't even i've got a null
check there um
and then you just call the ad source
method you say hey pretend this file
exists
and here's the source for it the file as
i say doesn't really exist
the name see how that says hint name the
name of the actual file that's produced
has a couple of goods in it so it's not
going to clash with anything you can
you know well you can't create the same
file name in the same generator by
calling ad source but
you don't have to worry about conflicts
like it's not real but essentially
that's it that's all you do to generate
code and
if you use that as a source generator
then your real project
will be able to access a class called
foo do nothing with it
um all right so some of the things you
want to do with your source areas
and this i'm just going to whip through
these slides really quickly because
i'll show you in a more realistic
scenario
so reading syntax the
if you're doing uh anything about say
removing runtime reflection
or generating you know automating code
you probably want to read the source
code of the project that is
using your source journal um and so
the way you do that is with the roslin
api there's lots of great talks and blog
posts
and all sorts of things on how to do
that with the relevant api i'm not going
to go into it
but just as a quick tips there's a
couple of cool tools
that i recommend so the syntax
visualizer is that picture on the right
hand side
it's built into visual studio if you
tick on the optional
compiler sdk component in the installer
and as you're clicking around your c
sharp code in vs
that's going to show you what the syntax
tree looks like
for that spot in the code and this is
really useful because
as your you start to inspect the code
you have to know how to how to do that
essentially right you have to know which
bits to pull out
um so this this syntax tree here
excuse me um this is for
a simple this bit of code here this main
and so you can see we have a namespace
we have a class declaration
uh we have an attribute list which may
or may not be empty
there's keywords there's all sorts of
but the
the syntax tree in general as i said
before is
really detailed so having a tool to let
you inspect what is in the syntax tree
is
super useful um if you don't have vs so
you don't want to use it for this
sharp lab is a website that has the
exact same feature
basically shows you the syntax tree of
any code you write um
job lab in general is awesome and does
some other things that are great too
um but that's another quick way to see
the
uh the syntax tree so that you kind of
you need to know what you're looking for
essentially so
uh let's say you were looking for
every method defined and you wanted to
do something with it well
you're going to be looking for these
method declarations but of course
they're inside class declarations and
they're inside namespace declarations
and
it gets kind of complex as you sort of
drill in
and there's lots of options around
things you could drill into and there's
lots of casting you often need to do
so a method declaration might have a
body but it also might have an
expression body
and those are two different things so uh
being able to just
sort of poke around the syntax trees is
really useful
and that's actually what i've got as the
third point there trial and error um
by far and away the biggest uh or the
most useful tool that i
use for this sort of thing is the
debugger inside vs
because if i get any kind of syntax node
i can just look at it in the watch
window and i can start to drill into it
super useful and then reading
symbols is the other side of looking at
code so syntax
is what the code looks like in the c
sharp
and then symbols is that meaning that
the compiler adds the compilation adds
so this is where you find out what types
things are etcetera
and there's a couple of sort of hints
here um
just very quickly so there's something
called the global namespace
this has everything that the compiler
or everything the compilation needs to
compile your code so that includes every
reference
dependency everything in the world this
is the entire world as far as the
compiler is concerned
so if you want to pull any information
about the code you're looking at
it will be in the global namespace
guaranteed because if it's not there
then the code doesn't compile get typed
by metadata name
is the sort of shortcut for reading that
info this is where you pass into that
method
system.string and it gives you back the
type for system.string
this is useful if you want to find
things tagged with an attribute you need
a reference to the type of the attribute
so you just put in that namespace and
away you go
get semantic model is how you get the
uh essentially the symbol information
for
this block of syntax that you have so
there's always these two worlds of
syntax and symbols and
getsematic model is how you sort of leap
from one to the other
this is where you say hey i found this
method declaration great
give me the semantic model for that so i
can start to see what types it returns
what types of parameters does it have
etc
you then call get symbol info on the
semantic model to find out the type
information
and then the syntax visualizer does have
some symbol stuff built in
it doesn't work very well although there
was a pr
a couple of weeks ago to hopefully fix
some of the issues
but again trial and error works really
well here if you've got
some bit of syntax call get symbol info
on it you'll get an i
symbol and then just look at that in the
watch window because it could be an eye
type symbol or
a namespace symbol or an i method symbol
whatever it is
but the debugger you know the watch
window will show you that info
you can drill into the properties you
can just start to get a feel and it is
it's relatively straightforward once you
start to do this because
you're familiar presumably with the code
that is being analyzed so
yeah and then generating syntax
this is where
things get interesting because this is
where it can be frustrating that you
have to use strings
but the flip side of that is using
uh any kind of higher level thing well
the higher level classes that the
compiler gives you are syntax notes and
so on the left there
excuse me which maybe you can't even see
because it's so tiny because there's so
much to it
those that is the code necessary to
produce
that code on the right hand side this
all comes from a website called ross and
quota
link there down the bottom so with
roslyn quota you put in that block of
code on the right
you click generate and it creates you
this code that's on the left
so that's easy enough to do and if you
want to use a higher level concept you
can do that
but as you can see it's very detailed
that actually on the left it even leaves
out some stuff that is not necessary
so it actually can get even longer if
you include everything
but the trap here so the very last line
of this
little snippet which maybe you can't see
but maybe you can it says normalize
white space
um and that's calling a method in the in
roslyn
that basically says hey here's some code
here's some syntax nodes i've generated
now make them
you know human readable the trap is if
you don't do that normalized white space
this is what that exact same code
produces without the normalized white
space code
and as you can see this is not valency
sharp so this is where if you were
providing a syntax tree
to the compiler directly you could run
into all sorts of problems because
you could give it invalid code
so anyway that's just something to keep
in mind you can use this if you want
um it really just depends how
complicated your generator gets and
there is a question in the slack what
are the real use case scenarios
i will run through a few of those in
just a second a good question
and then debugging a source generally i
think this is maybe the last
slide before we just chat a bit um
debugging the source genre is a little
bit of a challenge so
um if you want to debug your source
generator in a real project that you're
really using
then you can put in a call to
debugger.launch in the source generator
that will pop up a window and say hey
which visual studio do you want to use
and it'll
and it does all work and you can put
breakpoints in and everything worked
great
the issue is that that happens every
time there's a compile
and with visual studio every time you
type on the keyboard
it's going to be compiling your code so
if it gets far enough to run your
generator you might end up getting
flooded with these dialogues
so there's some edges there there is a
class in rollson called generator driver
which is designed for running source
generators
and so you can use that to create a test
app or unit tests
personally i find that to be the way to
go so there's a couple of links there so
sourcegen.dev
i will show you in a minute but that's
essentially a tool i wrote just to try
to make this stuff a bit easier to
reason about really quickly when you're
just starting out
or when you're making minor changes
there's also a link there to a source
generator template
repo that i made and it's essentially a
very simple source generator a very
simple unit test project for the source
generator
a simple console app that when you run
it it just
spits out the code the source generator
generated and a simple
app that uses the source generator as a
generator so it's basically
all four types of projects you could
want um and so that's sort of what i do
as my starting point i will grab that
repo
copy it you know duplicate it rename it
to whatever it is
and that's where i start working on
things and that way you can press f5 and
debug as normal
and then uh to task by chris
is the final link there so chris is the
the compilative who actually wrote
pretty much all of the source generated
infrastructure in the compiler
kititas is his project for essentially
allowing
f5 debugging of source generators really
easily
it's a it's a net sdk and global tool
it's
very tricky but really really clever
solution to the problem
i think that's it so let's
whip across to sourcegen.dev
so the question was is it more is it
more productivity enhancements rather
than performance improvements so
that's a really good question and i can
hopefully answer all of these things
because it can be both or it can be
everything so let me jump into
one example here so this is
sourcegen.dev
i built this because i was getting
frustrated at
using the trying to write source
trainers in front of reasoning about
them
and i built this i'm very glad to say
that it's
almost completely unnecessary now
because visual studio has caught up
which is great because i don't want to
pay to renew the domain name but it is
just sourcegen.dev if you want to muck
around
if you want to go there now and play
along that's fine
so what this is as you can see is four
text boxes
i am not the greatest web designer in
the world i freely offend it the theory
is
in this box on the top left is my
program code this is the code of my
application
or you know whatever it is this is the
thing that's going to
use the generator this is the thing
that's going to receive the generated
code if you like
on the top right we have the text of the
generator itself
so this is what does the work this is
going to look through my code and
analyze it etc
this then generates the output that is
in the bottom right this is
what this is the code that was generated
so you can see that here there's an
attribute and if we scroll up here you
can see this is
not an attribute the generated output
and the program code are then the two
things that are combined together and
then this is the output of running the
program
so that's basically how this works so
back to the question thank you muhammad
this would be an example of a
productivity enhancement so this is an
auto notify sample this is not written
by me this was written by
chris on the compiler team the theory
here is
so in very often in winforms or in wpf
a lot of desktop apps you want to
implement i notify property changed i
notify property changed
is a very simple interface that has a
property changed event
so every time a property is changed you
want to fire an event so someone
listening to that event can know when
things about your class change
and it gets kind of tedious because you
can't use so for example
uh let me just turn off auto refresh so
it doesn't compile as i type
but so if i type in here and i say
public screen
name i'm using an auto property here
so i can't easily implement i notify
property change because i need to
basically put some code in the setup
if i expand this setter out and i can
now you know
fire my own property change event well
that's great but now i need a field to
store my property in and i have to
convert this from a
auto property to a full property and so
it it sort of adds this cost
of um you know having to write a bunch
more code
which is not very exciting code it's
probably not going to be buggy code but
you never know
right so this is where as a productivity
enhancement what you can do with this
generator is you define a field
and you just put this attribute on you
say hello i'd like to be notified when
this field change
and what happens is down here if we look
the source runner is generating the full
property
for this field returning the value and
obviously this we've already defined the
field so this one doesn't have to
and then when the field is set we can
see it just fires this property changed
event
so this is a really simple example where
without any risk of you know typos or
anything else
we can implement i notify property
changed at almost no effort
and if we scroll down in this program a
bit here you can see here
we're accessing that text property from
that view model
the text property doesn't exist right it
is being generated so that's where this
is a partial class
we are generating the other half of this
class so this is a huge property boost
you can also do cool things like here
we're specifying the property name
of this property should be count so even
though the field is amount
if we scroll down in our generated
output we can see the count property
returns the amount uh field
so you can you know tweak and adjust the
generator now obviously that's a feature
of this generator not of source
generators in general
but these are the types of things you
can do
and then this runs and so if we comment
out this order notified property
uh oops i turned off auto refresh so now
what's going to happen
is our program's not going to build so
this is
i would still class this as a
productivity enhancement what's happened
here is you know as a developer i've
left off this
attribute you can see the generator has
still worked it's still run my
generation it's still generated my
account property but it hasn't generated
any other property
so here this line of code here this
vm.text
is line 24 right this is where the error
is because there is no text property
i didn't define it and i didn't define
the attribute that tells the source
generator to find it
so i still can't i mean this one's a
little bit complicated
convoluted i should say but i still
count this as a
uh productivity enhancement because this
is ensuring you don't forget essentially
right
you can imagine a system that worked at
runtime looking for these attributes
if you forget an attribute off one
property and then someone tries to use
that
mechanism in some way that would have to
be an exception at runtime
so at runtime your app's going to blow
up and say hey someone some developer
forgot
to add this line of code source
generators i get to
do that validation at compile time so i
get to break the build
which means you can't forget um
before we switch over to visual studio
one last thing is
or another example is this uh this is a
di
generator that i wrote just for a side
project uh so it's only for my needs
it's not very full-featured but i think
it's an interesting
it's an interesting concept and it's an
interesting way to
look at how you have to think to write a
source journal or
oh i need to turn off my refresh not how
you have to think
but you know what you can do so
what this is is a service locator right
normally
with di you would build up a container a
di container you would say hey
when someone asks for ifu right down
here we have our interfaces
when someone asks for an aifu use a foo
right you would add a scope to around
transient right singleton whatever you
do
the way this works is this source
generator
sees that you want to call getservice
and pass in an ifoo and as you can see
down here in the generated code
whenever you call get service this
returns my
through class right
i think this is a really cool example of
how source your owners
can well this is performance
more on the performance side for me but
source runners can
produce the most minimal code possible
so if you were writing a service locator
you would presumably want to check
and say right well what type do we want
to construct okay that one and i through
right well then i will construct a form
but you notice there's no if statements
here that's because
this source trainer knows what my code
looks like and it knows that i'm only
ever calling get service
asking for an ifoo so there's no need
for any
right if i ask for something else so
here i'm going to ask for an ibar
and i refresh my source channel will now
see two calls
and so now it knows to put in an if
statement so this is
this is definitely performance but i
think this is also productivity
because in essence i'm not having to
write
this library code that that sort of has
to
cater for all possible cases i can write
or i can generate
the simplest code possible so obviously
there's going to be some performance
wins there
but i think it's i think it's also a
little bit of both um and so this one
now
we're asking for two different types so
now it does have to do an if so it
checks if you want an i4 it's going to
give you the foo
but again there's no other if here we
know that there's only two types being
asked for so we can just go ahead and
give you the bar
this time it also generated lazies
because otherwise it would be slightly
inefficient if when you ask for a foo
you'd initialize both fields right and
you can get down into the weeds and
control that stuff as much or as little
as you like
in fact i think i yeah i put in
i put in a couple of little uh little
billions here to control this so i can
turn off this
and then now it just constructs objects
and if that's better for your needs then
great
do that you can control exactly what
this does because of course you're
authoring this generator
um if i what else can i do i can make
this
say that it's transient so every time
someone asks for a few
a foo i want a new one every time and so
this now generates just a constructor
call
right so it's the minimal code necessary
to do exactly the job
that my consuming code needs um
we can also get again we can get build
errors right so now i'm asking for an i
ibaz and there is nothing that
implements this so again
instead of a runtime exception because
hey you haven't filled in the container
properly or you forgot to wire this up
or you forgot to reference this dll
i get a build time failure that says
this was not going to work
i don't know when it was going to fail
but it was definitely going to fail at
runtime
so it doesn't even let you get that far
which i think is a super powerful
thing um so that's the di example
let's go over to visual studio for a
minute
so yeah if there's any questions on that
or anything else
please feel free to ask what i thought
i'd do
now is just sort of run through a little
bit end to end of
a source generator that i wrote kind of
still working but the pr still open
to improve i guess in this case this is
this is definitely
performance gain although realistically
it's probably about the same
performance wise as the existing
solution most cases
this is one that i would definitely
class as a productivity gain
but this one's a good one i think for um
this is essentially removing technical
debt in a way
um so the background here is the
winforms project
has or winforms in general has lots of
public api
that takes in enums right enums work
really well in the property grid in the
designer and so just historically they
were built up i guess
and so there's a lot of public api that
take enums which is great in theory
but as i suspect you know in c
sharp you can pass any old integer
to any enum and the compiler will let
you
you just cast the hint and away you go
and enum is not a strict set of values
at the moment um and so there was a
bunch of validation code in winforms
to ensure that all of the values passed
to all this public api were correct
so this is uh this is the actual
validation code from the winforms repo
and so you can see this is an unvalid
takes an enum takes in a value the
current value being set
takes in a minimum maximum value this is
the the bounds of that enum if you like
the check itself for validity is very
straightforward it's just
less than or equal to or you know
greater than or equal to
and then in debug there's some code here
i'll talk about that in a second
there was a bunch of other overloads for
this so they have a bunch of enums where
it's not a flag xenon but the values are
powers of two so there's this max number
of bits on to validate that at the end
of casting you should only have one bit
on
so this does a bit more code here this
bit operations.pop count still probably
fast but that's okay
when it's a flags enum just use the mask
that's okay we just have to pass this in
when it's a non-sequentially number
things get a bit worse so enum.getvalues
is using reflection
that's not ideal um it does only happen
in debug mode though so maybe it's okay
but now we've got to loop through and
check all these things
this is starting to get a bit worse
right and then if you look at all these
hash if debug
things what these do if we go to them
is these do heaps more validation again
only in debug mode
but all of these things do a bunch of
validation because the way you have to
call
these enum valid methods is you pass in
the current value you're validating
but then you have to pass in all of the
possible values for this e number you
have to pass in
all of the possible values for this
masked up or you have to pass in
what is the minimum and maximum value
for this enum so this is this huge
technical bet where every time you add a
value to an enum
you have to remember to update all these
validation calls if you don't there's
now this debug code that's going to add
validation that's going to throw an
exception at debug time
if you're running in debug of course and
then
it's actually funny because the
complexity of the debug validation
there's also this maximum case size here
where it caches some of the debug
information but eventually that cache
gets too big and so
there's all these layers and layers of
debt so
what we can do though is we can
completely replace that
so what i did after talking to a friend
of mine on the winforms team
because they got essentially they got a
pr to simplify all their enum validation
code
and it simplified it by not calling
those helper methods
and just doing that little simple math
in line
which was great in theory but of course
lost all of the validation to ensure
that it was kept up to date
so i was talking a friend of mine on the
team and i said well you know
we can do a source journal for this so
this this is the new call to validate
all you do is pass in this inner this
will do all of the validation that you
used to do
so the reason i'm in visual studio for
this is to show off some of the features
of visual studio
i can actually press f12 and i can go to
definition
on this validate method and let me just
put it side by side with my code
i missed oh no
oh no i think webex is not
liking that okay we're going to leave it
side by side with the code there
um and actually can you see that
that's oddly enormous there we go
okay so so this is the validate method
that is generated
for this simple enum case which is this
one over here
and as you can see the actual validation
is just as simple as it was before it's
just a minimum maximum
the difference is we're not passing in
the minimum maximum anymore
this just knows uh let me see if i can
get this to work
okay cool so watch what happens when i
add
another value to this this enum
i type a comma nothing happens i'm going
to type in the word
third but look at this one and watch
what happens as soon as i type t
the compiler is now generating my source
again
because of course it produced a new
compilation so even though i haven't
finished typing the name of this enum
which i will it's already updated this
to say two
so gone is me having to pass in what is
the maximum value for this enum
my source generator knows because it's
looking at my code and it's getting the
symbol information
and it's able to just output the right
values
this example here with this complex enum
type you can see these ones
aren't all you know neatly lined up so
this is doing
uh you know between three and four
inclusive and then between seven and
nine inclusive
if i change this to a 14 this generation
now we're never going to validate
against 3
then we're going to go between 7 and 9
and then we'll go to 14.
i can even change another one to 14 and
it's going to know
not to duplicate those values it's
changed this seven to an eight right it
can be super responsive so we get this
best of both worlds where
our enum validation is now super fast
this is you know
basically as fast as it can be is simple
integer comparisons i guess
although feel free to optimize this code
if you want
um but we also have these really simple
call sites
we don't have to do any uh you know we
don't have to help this by passing in
any extra information there's no
technical debt being added
because every time this changes we know
our generator is going to run
you cannot change right i cannot change
this enum
without the generator running because
the generator is run by the compiler
which is super powerful
so let me close this down and
let's just quickly have a look at the
search engines
so as i said we implement our source
generator that's fine
the way we find the code we want to
sort of trigger off in this case calls
to that validate method
is we use a syntax receiver now this
isn't the only way to do it but this is
the best
because what this means is so we say
register for syntax notifications
what this means is the compiler we tell
the compiler hey
i'm interested in knowing about the
syntax of this project
and every time the compiler sees an item
of syntax
any item in syntax it will call this
method
so this is the best way because this
means the compiler gets to be efficient
right rather than me
digging through every single piece of
code in the whole project
i just say let me know when you see a
node and if that node doesn't change
then it doesn't need to call me again
it knows all these things and so
basically what we do is
we get every single syntax node comes to
us
and we just check is this something i'm
interested in
in this case well i'm interested in
method indications that's an invocation
expression
i want it to be only an invocation of a
method called validate
only if it's on a class called enum
validator or
in a validator this is a little bit of
the uh sometimes uh annoyance of using
the rosin sdk or
or rather of using c syntax trees
because they're so detailed if you have
enum validator.validate or enum
validation which is the namespace that
individual
those are completely different syntax
trees and so sometimes this does get
annoying you have to allow for
for both um there is a higher level of
syntax which is called eye operation
which sort of takes away some of this
pain
so there are alternatives but for this
simple case i'm just checking both cases
both forms and then so basically
if i find a method to a call to a method
called validate on a class called enum
validator
that has two arguments and this is
really just belt and braces
uh i just add this to my list i say hey
i think i found a call i think i found
an argument
to this validate method that i should
validate add it to my list
so that's that's my finding of syntax
essentially the compiler is going to
call me it's going to say hey here's a
node
doughnuts and then when we actually
execute
the generator in this generator method
all i'm going to do is i'm going to go
through my arguments that i found
so i pull them out of my syntax
receivers hey go through my arguments
that i found
and i just process them and then here
i'm basically i'm getting the enum type
doing a little bit some validation um
i check if it's a flag flag's enum and
that's it
the way that source generators work best
is if you
think like you're writing a compiler so
the compiler has has phases right we
have a pars phase where we build a tree
and then we have a compile phase where
we
process that tree your source generator
is best if it can do the same thing so
in this case
i am building up these enum validation
info objects
and these validation info objects are
the thing that goes through and
this method here finds all of the
members of my enum so i'm building up
all this information
but you notice i'm not generating any
code yet
so after i get if we go oops
back up here where are we so this line
of code here
is basically saying go and build up
this this information this library of
information about what you're going to
need to do
and then we process it so firstly if we
didn't find any
then i'm just outputting a empty stub of
a method just so that something is there
for intellisense to to key off right so
that
users have an easier time this is
actually optional you don't need this
but if we do find something then i call
the generate method so i build up all my
information
then i generate it and then this is
where i'm generating and as you can see
these are just strings
and it's not the nicest looking thing in
the world but it's not that hard
i don't know maybe it's just me i don't
find this that horrible that i want to
use some kind of higher level object um
object mapping maybe some people do
that's fine
but all this does we output an xml
comment we output our method signature
right which has the enum type in it and
then we generate our method body
and the method body is simply there's
two different forms one is for flags one
is for non-flags
and all these things are outputting is
the series of checks
so for flags xenons it's just one we we
get the total
uh you know the total sum of all of the
flags and we just validate
easy if there's ever a new member added
to this enum it's going to appear
because it'll be part of this loop which
means our total get updated
which means our generation gets updated
and then for
non-flags we just output all those lift
statements you saw
so each little chunk of this is
relatively straightforward
this method here is probably the most
complicated which is
trying to work out the bands so we've
got you know
one two three seven nine that's trying
to work out the bands in the enums this
was the most complicated code i wrote
and this one was the bit that took the
most trial and error
the rest of this is pretty
straightforward and the
power that you end up getting in terms
of
how simple this is but how safe it is
and how
you know no technical deci it is um
i think is really you know really good
win and a really big argument for
this sort of thing
and that's basically me uh if there's no
other questions
i'm going to show this slide for no
reason um i'm happy to run through
anything else we've got about five
minutes left so if anyone has any
questions feel free to chuck them in
slack
um
yeah hopefully you may be uh
interested in source jers let's say i
don't expect anyone to remember any of
the things that i actually
said there because using the rosin api
can be
sometimes painful it's good to refer to
other blog posts and things at the top
as you go but yeah there's certainly
lots of possibilities
do you have that particular example that
you gave us there david as a repository
or something
available i don't that's not about i can
put that i could put it up um
it is uh it's it's an open pr on the
winforms repo if you want to have a look
um but yeah no i
actually i can i can just push this as
it is um
i will uh i will do that and i'll put a
link in the slack
it's an excellent example of the power
that you can do and how to set it up
i would really appreciate that yeah i
really like this one
because so in the in the pr
hello in the pr for this uh one of the
first comments
was like on this line of like hey this
this approach is too simplistic what if
we add a new enum value
and you really i always think of that
back to the future quote
of um you're not thinking fourth
dimensionally when uh they're talking
about driving off the bridge and marty's
like but the bridge isn't there it's
like it will be
um it's it's kind of a little bit
mind-bending sometimes to think about
this of like
you have to call so actually the other
thing i can do which is interesting
so uh if i comment out this method here
there's no validation method or this
enum type
so i have to call this method blindly
knowing that you know my safety net will
catch me and then i have to not worry
about the fact that this method
only validates two things again it's
that safety net of
they will be there if they need to be um
which is kind of
it takes a bit of getting used to think
that way um so yeah i'll put up this
example that's
that's totally cool that'll be awesome
cheers
that works how does this align with the
linker
the linker so the the interesting thing
is
this should in theory work really well
with the linker because
anytime you remove reflection and write
a world can generate the code that
generated code
is using you know whatever methods and
properties you are getting from
reflection
it's using them for real so you don't
need to tell the link that they're being
used because they actually are
so this should work really well with the
linker um
it'll be very interesting to see what
happens in terms of
what internal microsoft things will be
rewritten to use source generators so
things like asp.net endpoint routing
even razer blazer file generation could
be rewritten with source generators
and there's pros and cons to all of that
in particular that's where some of the
concerns about you can't have multiple
come up
so for example if asp.net routing
uses a source generator then you can't
use the source generator to generate
routes because those two things won't
see each other right the asp.net one
won't be able to see your generated code
so it'll be interesting how that sort of
falls out but yeah in terms of the
linker that all happens
on the il after the compilation so this
stuff plays really well with it and can
actually i think be a big help
cheers no worries
if there's no other questions i guess uh
you can go get another coffee or
whatever it is we do in these virtual
conferences